[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone my name is Jake and I'm
here with Mike we're gonna play
injustice to for you this is part of our
daily 11 o'clock stream uh but let's get
right into it shall we yeah well um so
those who don't really know might not be
familiar you and I work on a show called
reboot on Sundays yeah
check it out if you have the time it's
good yeah so it's bi-weekly and we we
put up an actual episode every other
week and it's more of like an opinion
editorial show but then in the off weeks
we do like a Q&A and have people like
sending comments and stuff and suggest
future episodes what to talk about we
try to just take like a newish game or a
topic in general and kind of look at it
from a different angle but we talk about
injustice too on the most recent episode
so we figured we're gonna try to keep
this going and play the games we talk
about the following Monday to preface I
am not traditionally into fighting games
that's actually kind of what the
episodes about but I really like this
one and it's actually encouraged me in a
lot of cool ways to get into it more and
learn its mechanics and kind of
overlapping systems in general and I
have a few characters I really like and
I've been learning them and it's been
really fun and I like it a lot
Andre says hi I'm like um so also if
gameplay seems too low or we seem to
well let me know I can adjust the levels
if you guys have any questions for
either Mike or I or about injustice we
can try to help but like my like what
Mike said we at least I personally not
the best at fighting games you're you're
a bit better than I am so yeah yeah so
we figured those who are not familiar
with it this is the multiverse it's just
kind of single-player daily rotating
challenges sometimes weekly but I just
saw that this one is going to give me
rare green arrow gear so I figured I'd
do this I'll play a few different
characters throughout it like if you're
in the chat if you want to see specific
characters and see different characters
super moves we could do that I'm gonna
start off with green arrow cuz he's my
strongest and I also get rare green
arrow gear looks downhill after yeah
I'll kick it off an axe says hello Mike
and you can kind of see it what's up you
can kind of see how I've customized a
few my characters sometimes like in the
case of the flash I don't think his
helmets that cool right now but that's
the best helmet I have in terms
stats and you could see Italy level for
whereas like Green Arrow's up a little
more up there is 11 like green arrow
green beats ask what platform you're
playing on this is ps4 yeah so I'll
start off the green arrow but then give
me suggestions who you want me to play
as in the next few matches so the
multiverse event I have to play through
eight characters for this one to
complete it so I'll do that and that
won't be an hour so then after that we
can get into maybe show the intro to
story mode um so now it says lots of
love Mike and hi to you too Jake
thanks um cool ha
Callie's in the twitch chat complaining
about me every month I tweet that banjo
tooie better than Canaries
because I like telling the truth masses
she doesn't mean arrow looks pretty cool
yeah oh so here's this so multiverse
also has modifiers um got a nice arrow
wholly blocked it so in this particular
match see I can call in myself as a as a
helps out is cuz multiverse so yeah this
that's the modifier for this multiverse
it's a green arrows like a kind of a you
know an assist move and then you got
environmental interactions like BAM
that's pretty cool ice arrows my one of
my favorite things then you can get a
heavy attack in on them show you my crab
it's pretty cool he's actually kicking
the show I'll show you the super rule
oh my sensei says can you customize
characters in this game yeah you can
yeah a lot they're actually gear and
stand up here so this is his super ice
arrow I love it and then he just [ __ ]
falls on cuz some vision is something
you actually talked about in the episode
of yeah it is the way that kind of keeps
you coming back to it yeah and I messed
around a little bit and got some cool
stuff but yeah you can you can make let
your heroes as well can cheer below you
can make these iconic heroes with my
attacks with my favorite things here
go I'll show you I grabbed Ivan ji asked
the question is three he wants to know
so guys should I buy this game yeah I
liked him a lot
and I'm not traditionally fighting games
like I said I have a boxing arrow or a
boxing glove arrow I can show you I get
back up when will it come to PC they
haven't announced it yet I think they
hinted it a PC release but I don't share
not don't sure about that yeah all right
and then Adam pearl wants to know do you
play with joystick joystick or d-pad I
play with the pad when I play because I
want those precise inputs but I don't
even know if that's the best way to do
it it's like yes I like I really like
using joystick though I got it pretty
cool try to get my get away attack to
finish it off oh damn guy yeah yeah
alright um so yeah so you see if you're
not familiar with a game you get credits
you get character by experience then you
get player experienced player experience
lets you get into different that
actually just gives you different
bonuses and whatnot but all that green
arrow look cool again someone says you
think Darkseid will be available for
everyone even if they didn't pre-order
apprec you can buy him I think when I
was playing I had the option to buy him
but there is an event I think it's still
going on right now you can play as
Darkseid quite a bit
oh really even if you don't have him
even if you don't have him yeah
wait weird I guess it's an enticing way
to get some because I played like must
have played like an hour with him
yesterday and I was like alright well I
kind of want to like mess around with
them and then I realized I haven't
leveled up I hadn't unlocked anything
for those like ah okay Ivan Jesus is
$5.00
yeah it's already available to buy Andre
asks what's your favorite DC character
Mikey um DC character I think I would
have to go with Batman um not to be a in
the game or like in general uh he didn't
specify he just says DC character so I
don't know favorite DC character yeah
probably babe Batman
I also really I kind of like green arrow
in a weird way although he's kind of
cheesy I think it's a point though do a
little come on and what you watch arrow
at all Mike a little bit I don't like it
at all I used to like Superman more than
I do now especially the way he's
conveyed in this game kind of I don't
really love and I think that's kind of
on purpose yeah I think I missed yep yep
or the DLC is worth the money I don't
know I didn't get any the DLCs I won't
probably buy any the open fighting games
DLCs are usually pretty you know like it
new characters big deal yeah I mean yeah
if you're really into it's probably
worth money for me personally while I'm
enjoying it I'd probably go yeah
all right here you kick you in an hour I
love the environment interactions yeah
like I'll try to do a stage transition
if I can get him up there one thing I
just love about all netherealm games you
know I'm not super into fighting games I
just love how like bombastic and how
exaggerated their eyes come down a
little bit miss I got stop talking okay
I'll stop talking no you can talk
understand I got a stop I know I'll stop
asking you questions who's the best
fighter in this game so far it sounds
like Deadshot yeah Opie won at the
moment there you can watch where you
know this will kill him yeah I just
wanted to end on the super because I was
talking too much and green is so Green
Arrow's my strongest but yeah Deadshot
has this getaway attack if you see the
one I'm using I like green arrow because
although he's range focused he's also
got some pretty good up-close text oh
[ __ ] okay so here you go you can I could
equip it right now although I don't want
to because I kind of value ability
damage over health but I can I'll get
into the actual gear Awards do we have
any suggestions for who I want to play
next anybody yeah is there any well is
there any character
you guys want to see we can bring up the
Oh looks like it's gonna keep going male
right you I'll start with green arrow
but if I die you can select a new
fighter okay um Aquaman yeah actually I
just started playing off on that a
little more last night I like it a lot
does the amount of DLC turn you guys off
in this game I feel like it feels like
you can't get the full experience
without paying a lot of money I mean I
think there's quite a bit of content
here as is there's actually a lot like
between the single-player the multiverse
all the loot tons of characters right
off the bat I'm trying to get come over
here so I can do an environmental thing
here we go man however if you are one of
those people who like to have everything
I guess that can be kind of overwhelming
yeah so see that again
I like that get away but Deadshot's get
away attack is pretty overpower
apparently yeah um lightning says he
mains Harley Quinn I like Harley Harley
Quinn did really good - yeah
actually this might be a good
opportunity - is this the transition
over on the side of the stage I know I
think eras on the right yeah travel
super I can show clash Oh [ __ ] blocked
it
[Music]
got him little bit which Niecy character
do you think has the most interesting
backstory I seen a lot of Flash
recommendations I like black school yeah
people who say in flash people say talks
I can have dark side yeah I don't have
the I did not get the I just plain of
vanilla game won't happen illa but
without him
um interesting DLC character I would say
I want someone ask me what I think the
dumbest character is in this game
because there's some dumb characters
gorilla grodd's pretty clearly wrong
although he's actually fun to use I
don't usually like Brookshire he's fun
but yeah alright so I get the stage
transition yeah oh it's not on this side
it is the bottom but try taking him over
there oh I thought covered a different
map come over here stop it okay I give
you back to fighting you won't see the
here show you the boxing glove arrow
it's pretty pretty dumb okay he's almost
dead I'd want to get land on the street
oh I don't know if it'll have a screen
schedule on now hold on yeah you look at
daddy the red one come here we're gonna
squeeze you he might cuz you're doing
backflips like a dumbass
let's trying to get him over to the bus
for the street stage transition it's
definitely through the bus I think he
bounced off the bus and go into the
asylum alright we've seen a lot of flash
Oh and lightning says firestorm is the
dumbest our storm definitely surprising
I don't know how our storm is super dumb
but like I didn't realize firestorm is
to people and then his power is like
fight like how does that make sense it's
literally just like atomic fire but then
he's fire that's his power like
shouldn't be like mind control or some
[ __ ] if you're two people come by I
don't know yeah I don't know someone to
tell me the stage transition was on the
right side I thought I I did it it
didn't work I who knows so flash I'll do
flash um I could can I pause and just
change my fighter right now I I think
you should keep going till you lose
enough to switch okay
but it seems like flash has been the
overwhelming one that people want to see
okay so I think after we should
definitely do flash
okay lightning yeah
Harley good Harley's are tough to beat
oh that was nice
that's probably my favorite attack in
the game is kind of you can yeah I love
that too
I really like I'll get this car thing
here gab says none of these characters
is dumb as having alien predator and
Mortal Kombat that was weird I kind of
liked that they were there yeah well
Mortal Kombat also has the horror
characters had a Freddy Krueger in here
Michael Myers where was it no Jason and
Michael what's Freddy in it - I think he
was I think I don't know if Michael
Myers was in it no I don't know maybe
someone the chat would know I know for
sure Freddy Krueger was I remember
seeing like trailer set the freezer and
then getting close um Hartley's power
you can see the two dogs she got those
hyenas that she throws he shows it just
threw one at me you should throw the
alligator at her like it's more for
transitions oh it is I some of them are
based on the character like um I think
Superman would throw it but i'm i like
people without super-strength well like
just use it - it's good for getting up
all you [ __ ] it's good for getting up
and Grant Wilson says a black hand or
Constantine for DLC I don't think
Constantine is DC I'm pretty sure he's
busy
Dark Horse yeah I don't think he's that
would be rad though cuz I love cons he
netted Constantine's dope character it
was Jason and Michael I would I don't
think it right he wasn't it Jason I just
see Jason Freddy Freddy was mk9 woops
wrong there we go
Leatherface - yeah Leatherface
here we go - oh I like that combo I was
cool he's got this one combo that I
don't really pull off too well but it's
pretty oh I also I can show off his um
oh here to clash so she's probably gonna
wager all of it and I saw it so I just
so I don't lose anything yeah we tied uh
you know you want to explain that while
I fight the clash you don't know yeah I
don't know if I fully get it basically I
mean that's mine why should I kill her
I'll just do this but you essentially
clash and you wager how much of your
meter you have and whoever wagers more
wins oh nothing at the ready was more
kind of nine than Leatherface and Jason
were MKX wait Constantine is DLC
Constantine is DC uh I'm gonna look this
up I don't know if he's in Justice
League dark justice comic alright show
so much you know I guess I don't know
anything you comment DC Comics imprint
oh I didn't know vertigo in DC I left my
universe for this I know I know I didn't
really trust this is a pretty gross
character throws up blood in your mouth
for his grab he's a Red Lantern he's
like Green Lantern's and nemesis kind of
um come on sometimes to know how we
don't watch any CW shows or any of the
DC shows no I just couldn't get into him
I used to watch Smallville and I watched
arrow a little bit and flash or no flash
is yeah everyone's everyone's telling me
Constantine is DC well then if that's
the case I would love to have to
Constantine in this I was one of the few
people who actually enjoyed the Keanu
Reeves Constantine moving
Kodak flexes their playing on ps4 you
what's the preferred way Xbox could so I
could show you I got this attack no it's
not doing it here we go so shoot the
arrow up in the air and this it's kind
of hard to land but it's good for our
range games taking the [ __ ] on you
crosses and good combos I haven't used
it much put your head as a damn yeah
damn it show off his super movie ah why
did you use it there actually yeah
whatever
probably good for you yeah so these are
pretty brutal
I like captain cold for a lot of these I
think is the most brutal one yeah the
dog the hyena just eat you yeah
[ __ ] I just try to do that to him okay
dumb cat
I love that oh [ __ ] I think I'm gonna
win this one says they want Jack from
the shiny [ __ ] yeah in Mortal Kombat
have it go be a here's Johnny
ocean yeah there it is vomit blood on
you and then pixie right now
freezin quick I'm gonna use that convoy
like nope um also for those who don't
know GameSpot we're trying to stream
every day Monday through Friday at 11
a.m. so make sure to tune in we'll be
streaming all sorts of different things
Monday's usually it's gonna be Mike and
I after reboot will play a game we
talking about in reboot or if there's
nothing really relevant mantley
something else maybe and then Fridays we
do John Luke and Joey through indie
stream ice all switched to uh the flash
it sound like if you want you just want
to see the flash okay uh but yeah keep
checking back every day we'll have these
games 11 a.m. Pacific um
yeah like the flash he's got a cookies
got a lot of cool moves in terms like
cuz reverse-flash can travel back and
forth through time and you fight him in
the campaign but it's an alternative
flash
that one I love that I've been G wants
to know if we're gonna play online
probably not
I don't know likes feeling confident not
really but I guess I'll try it out your
Flash yeah outfit is pretty sick
yeah he's blue for those i like his one
where he punches them a ton e than they
react later yeah yeah that one's
reverse-flash is better than flash mike
says i said huh
yeah you said that no i didn't i said
he's got it this guy's Mike Tatum
Oh gotcha this one's pretty dumb it's
the T right yeah let me check its move
list out quick uh I think Fist of Fury
is the one you were talking about I'll
try it out yeah this is it yeah and I
really like this one too whoop that one
bucks oh man he got you in a combo
Atrocitus combos are good people want
you to do online but the prototype is
saying online is annoying with dead shot
okey there we go is that one that one's
pretty good that would say you Atrocitus
oh I hate that thing um yeah characters
in the multiverse block damn oh man
[ __ ] actually maybe not everyone I
think only ones that say any level and
they match but some of them say like you
should be level and those ones I'm
assuming they'll match better no I
haven't done it
get green arrow in here
I missed I'll finish him is super well
the beginning of a super can you put on
God speed skin I do not have it I don't
think of it good gear for who
speaking of Smallville yeah after I
finish this I'm a diversified I'll go
into the gear and show people who feel
like seeing I in case I die who did
people want to see next
yeah we'll keep going with flash until
we die but after that a lot of
characters I did see I'm actually liking
the vote these are kind of my oh I saw
one yes Aquaman I saw it underwent
wonder wonder whamon I stuck with aqua
home it up for Wonder Woman I'll play
her a Wonder Woman or Supergirl I saw
that too I like Supergirl more but
looking for a hot date yeah would you
date poison ivy Mike as long as I wore
rubber lips like Robin didn't the movie
she can be annoying cuz she summons that
like the thing that I think the most
annoying character I've played against
it was cuz I was dark side too so I was
doing my best character was yeah what
the [ __ ]
uh you'd be the story right yeah because
yeah that's like it's like sucks that's
from the store [ __ ] she's taking the
[ __ ] on me I got to use this quick most
annoying character I had to fight was a
cyborg for some reason so I was kicking
my bucket I like cyborg a lot I played
him recently I want to get the UM
alright I see Bane Blue Beetle Blue
Beetle cheetah Bane Blue Beetle I like
probably the same person thing know is
um sometimes it is this is lion-o we go
what about full I see lots of you said
you like Blue Beetle I see lots of blue
beetle and cheetah
Wonder Woman is dope I love her moveset
and specializing nonsense nonsense music
poison ivy
kind of tough to fight she's got a lot
she's like pretty varied ranges well it
looks like I could kiss me [ __ ] you nice
I've got it got over her
jack is a badass no Jack is beast so I
love Green Lantern
I'm play come on here we go there we go
all right I'm coming back I think not
speak too soon though
yeah don't jinx it oh come on yeah I
think I got it
yeah I think you did
passionately I love that the dinosaur
just like Fez is like what the [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] he's now in a deal oh you have
a favorite ultimate in this game are
super sorry not ultimate it's not
[ __ ] overwatch uh I have to think but
I really like super girls are going
around the Sun yeah I don't like
Superman's new one as much like his in
the first game was kinda like super
girls he brings into outer space and
then throws him back at Earth in this
one have you seen it
he throws them and then just punches
them and then speeds up in the sky yeah
to punch him and then he catches them by
the face we've got some good ones we had
uh commands of Cartman's agent or
society Cartman I don't need I've not
played dr. fate at all yet Stevie says
you boys are good at this Wow I don't
I'm not playing so you in my hands just
mike is playing try to do that I'll try
to that punch attack you like ya can't
do it though come on alright I'm [ __ ]
it up people who say play dr. fate to
ice off with him alright I haven't use
dr. fate at all sorry that's what I
meant to say right in the side that's
cool one flash get a combo and [ __ ]
together spat I like him obviously he's
fast
[ __ ] he'll feel it stretching Oh God I
like alcaman a lot
kicking the [ __ ] out of me yeah is you
just a catch-up try to get the
transition on this map I think it's to
the left I don't think I've done
anything yet should you decide who you
wanna play it seems like we're getting a
lot of blue beetle I'll do blue Bo yeah
I like blue beetle he wasn't he's not
super inching character to me in terms
of like DC ship I use a fun fighter
all right I guess I can play them now
cuz Aquaman just destroyed philanthropy
says we should get some matches where
you guys fight each other Mike would
kick my butt we have another control
I'll do blue Beale I got I did get the
grid skin for cyborg oh that would be
cool to look at you yeah when we look
through uh yeah sets to check out the
grid skin yeah sure I actually can't
wait for sub-zero I'm like Mike tan was
just talking about it
so it's sub-zero Red Hood and I forget
the girl's name she's like a
supernatural princess of some sort I
believe looks like a Red Hood I would
probably yeah cool me right so I don't
know boo Beals movesets on me
I like blade barrage I like blade stab
like switching to the blades yep like
that I like that one I just want to keep
the [ __ ] up and now he just embarrassed
me last time someone says Starfire
Starfire would be cool Starfire Raven
the only reason I know them is Cle to
watch Teen Titans all the time though
that show is rad
what's the what's my [ __ ] ghetto he's
super right now about the blades alright
to the blades [ __ ] you off man alright
aqua is one of those ones I like playing
as he also kicks a [ __ ] on me every time
I fight him for one whatever reason this
one's alright it's not something he just
morphs he's kind of like a Green Lantern
suit almost he can although not as much
as many possibilities nice I do have a
judge for every I do have a different
skin on for blue beetle right now okay I
don't think we forgot Starfire I said he
said Starfire would be cool and
something else pointed out or maybe
someone else in the chat forgot about
stuff
oh no they're saying Starfire's the
other one coming okay
that's the other care ah no that's not
yeah I don't that you can look it up I
don't think it is is that her is that
her name
uncle man I'll look it up I mean I got
stop talking cuz I'll commands kicking
the [ __ ] out of me
his super is going on her now if you
don't see this though it's pretty good
super I vote blue beetle again oh I got
some new arms I could wear this stuff
it is Starfire looks like Starfire Red
Hood oh that's her name
yeah yeah cool okay spawn is coming two
years that way ridings coming to dance a
lot oh uh I don't see Raven here what
I'm looking at I see I mean people in
chat seems like they already notice
darkside obvious it's already out Red
Hood Starfire sub-zero and then a raid
in black mantas spawn he does new helmet
I just got four blue beetle oh yeah cool
and then three mystery ones where the
last three it looks like
man I said I didn't want the DLC but I
kind of want one her idea in Starfire
and sub-zero looks pretty cool - problem
is I don't want to keep paying for these
characters come back here man planted
really hate by land 50 said spawn did
when the guest character fall someone
says ridin is not to you but I see
riding on the list I'm looking at here
but that's I don't think that's is that
official let me use my super quick [ __ ]
him up uh yeah maybe I don't know if
this is trustworthy see I just got that
new helmet last match actually I think
is pretty cool looking all right sweet
damn it now he's gonna regain all that
can't crush this bucket damn he's gonna
get a lot back alright pretty much even
it out
oh well scrap foxes I love spawn but why
the F would he show up in a DC games
property of Image Comics yeah I didn't
think he was DC either but last time I
said I didn't think someone was DC
everyone jumped down my throat I didn't
say anything but I'm certainly not
complaining I like spawn I remember you
don't play Soul Calibur - yes a lot I
played a lot of that game - I remember
they did that thing I forgot ps2 I ain't
got you B I forgot X a lot the special
characteristics ps2 there's hi Hachi
from Tekken ok but Xbox it was spawned
with Brad and then on games it was late
yeah and I did not like him who he's
he's cool yeah it was really cool but I
didn't I stuck with him
damn
oh man Aquaman all right I'm gonna try
some else besides Blue Beetle because
I'm sucking with him right now
Yolo MC swag says do you not even notice
me we noticed you alright I'll try
who else can I try right now I guess I
could do Aquaman V Aquaman sure I'll do
that for now I saw a couple Hawkins I'm
getting a couple black Canary's - Black
Canary is cool I like Puff she's got
like a couple counters that are really
good if you know how to use her so
that's the day Aquaman's label -
GameCube version still kalbi twos the
only performing I agree I played on ps2
pep-talk um yeah goob Shu says group
says Edie Boone's pools for polis for
spawn held wide terminator or [ __ ]
terminator would be interesting
I feel like terminator would fit better
in Mortal Kombat though yeah
well boy would be cool can you even tell
which ones me well I mean obviously the
guy Kento but I've been looking away and
just by the health taking the [ __ ] out
of the [ __ ] pissed at him throw my
trident
both got our supers now yeah like I'll
comment a lot actually
[ __ ] you you're not gonna hit me from
there
I love his you dodge it he just looked
so dumb yeah that's nothing slowly
released rygan I like his grab to
[ __ ] crack it comes out oh here we go
here we go look at scene transition if I
can back him up damn I don't know if I'm
close enough for now like no way he is
not having it no scene transition [ __ ]
you
damn I wish I could freeze I love Green
Arrow because it's so easy once I freeze
them just go up and do it chaos in the
background
no little MC swag because I hope Aquaman
wins I do too we're gonna clash for them
quick [ __ ] you
we go
[ __ ] you
nope Wow no man now he's gonna combo me
no no it's classic now he's gonna get
all that back 15 20 % hey five all right
whatever
he's now showing the final wish what do
you think the final wishes about Locke
and everything
oh we're going on it
like Green Arrow's killin alright
finally got best Aquaman I'll keep
playing Aquaman a little bit Robin I
want to play I wouldn't get really good
with Rob he's just really [ __ ] cool
in this game there's a sword in the hood
Damian Wayne Bane I usually kick the
[ __ ] out of for whatever reason I'm
better against slow big characters so
the next two hopefully but I said that
about Atrocitus too so since we're
fighting Bane do you have any a Bane
impression no I can't do that on the
spot crashing this plane the fire rises
he's such a scary character he is yeah I
love the witty banter in this game a
couple of members the Justice League in
this fire right now Green Arrow is
Justice League right oh god I don't know
[ __ ] you
nice ah [ __ ]
oh man I'll do my super on him this
one's pretty
what oh yeah this one's pretty
ridiculous the world just because I'm in
the ocean one really I have seen this
one yeah and then at the end is damn
alright then all the water evaporates I
keep forgetting I have the green arrow
system I'm not using it enough there we
go so you said that's part of this
multiverse yeah that's part of this this
event yeah okay multiverse event I'm
gonna throw this tire and when I get
back up
Yolo MC swag as a bad impression here I
will break you and you'll spirit
that what we painted who have dried on
the ground and like laid there like poo
no idea oh he was trying to it's a
body-slammed he missed Magisters Green
Arrow's yes nice this game almost
encourages me to want to go more into DC
except but then this game I'm interested
because of the game not like I don't
know I haven't found any character bios
I hadn't looked deep enough but I know
who most these characters are but like I
don't know who blue beetle was before I
started playing this or firestorm or
cheetah I didn't know yeah those three I
didn't know who they were
Captain Cold I'd never heard of before I
hadn't heard of Captain Cold
Swamp Thing is I feel bad beat him up
because he's actually a nice dude and he
just cares about a swamp in the story
it's a rad looking Swamp Thing yeah the
one thing about his classes are all the
skins are variants of like earth and
swamp
well swamp things kicking the [ __ ] out
of you for messing with this swamp maybe
not
his his crouch is really funny feel he
was like sinks into a guru yeah just
down to his waist
yeah well you [ __ ]
damn you really got me
well gee the UH
oh I haven't seen this damn that's
brutal I know it's pretty cool though
this is just fruit from the ground well
looks like we're gonna be switching
characters huh nah dude I got it
I'm all good I'll catch up wait you got
our one it looks like yeah some things
another one of those just block that try
to whittle him down
don't [ __ ] dodge this there we go
all right think I'd catch up no I think
I can I don't think so
what do you think check to Mike Wynn I
think he's just gonna land one dumb
punch on the anywhere loose like that do
him some on things tough to fight to
he's got those like he's kind of got the
supergirl thing he'd come from behind
you
who shut find out who else what they're
saying nonsense really wants us to watch
DC shows and then justice I'll select
some what a shot who should I uh uh so
we got a lot of Black Canary we got some
Harley Quinn I'll do Harley before I do
Black Canary I don't know Black Canary
at all
I'll finish this off with Harley she's
fun she's got this tantrum pose it's
called he could do a lot of cool moves
out of that I'd like when she slides
down and shoot someone a ton that's it
cool oh you could do a cartwheel out of
it you can do a bomb or you can do the
the guns yeah yellow swags this poison
ivy is BAE sounds like she might have
poison you though tantrum Oh back in axe
here we go I'll show you that I'll shoot
a gun thing
yeah that's or you can do a cartwheel or
you can do the bomb nope that's
cartwheel [ __ ] bomb that was gone no
this is the bomb I just wanted to go
there's a bomb there it is yeah she's
fun and one more
[ __ ] you Swamp Thing alright making
short work of it this time
nice look at the guns I have like this
is my I played Harley a little bit and
she's this is my costume
obviously I'll do her super her super is
pretty vicious hold on let me throw it
let me do some greener I keep forgetting
I have green arrow right now have you
read any um DC Comics at all yeah um I
was really like Superman red Sun for
those who don't know it's like as if he
landed the Soviet Union instead of
Kansas okay and he him and Batman it's
like a reimagining of everybody like
cold war [ __ ] it's really cool that's
too cool the block is I've only read
like some of the like the famous Batman
comics like oh yeah Dark Knight Returns
already I've read Arkham Asylum
Kashia Halloween long Halloween is
something I still don't actually read
The Killing Joke though which is read
that yeah the ones that also inspired
the first injustice or a part of the
storyline
come on to the grabb I want to do the
grab before he kills don't [ __ ] kill
me
alright so I'll show you the gear we got
from this it's a good finish taunt
ending I guess I got some arms for her
what level am i I'll equip that alright
a lot of the gear screen show people is
this that was this the last match of
yeah nice I don't think I got I don't
would not have got gold I've been
talking too much to kill everybody
straight in the row - I didn't get
silver oh you're so close yeah I think
if I hadn't died what four times yeah um
there we go okay good that's the
character I like Joker arms too as well
as a couple silver mother boxes go back
out to do this stuff it show people the
AI battle simulator care but doctor says
Kingdom Come is a must-read who's that
about who is that about it's all open
these this is for people I don't know
this is the random loot boxes that kind
of death unbound asks what are we
watching this multiverse we actually
just finished multiverse that we're
going to open up some boxes and then I
think we're going to take a look at loot
we need to the cyborg grid yeah
I just got a new shader for Robin flash
Michael Maragos I think that yeah
Michael Maragos is this game is
addictive can't put it down it seems
like you are in a similar boat and your
name is also Michael that's me in the
chat and texting under well um simple
things to stuff right now every guy was
an epic Superman no black Adam he's
pretty fun to use I use in a little bit
yesterday I haven't used them did you
choose Aquaman in the storyline when you
go to use Black Adam cool I could buy a
gold one now just to buy that with
twenty five thousand credits here we go
see what else I get too many credits in
this game too many different currencies
yeah the guild ones I actually made a
guild just to see if people want to get
into it they the challenges look hard
alright so get out of that I'll join you
alright no I won't I've been honest box
1 so how do you yeah here we go uh my
buddy back home is a DC fan he got this
yeah alright I'll play with you so I'll
go to Green Arrow quick just to see what
cuz he's my main dude tackle armor
where'd I get the ten one is that better
so these all look kind of cool um don't
I want a Cyberman says Dark Knight
Returns his favorite graphic no that's a
good choice health
don't let this may be more health no I
like his ability keep whoo that's a cool
one though which one go down that one's
pretty cool but yeah I would go for got
some new arms Dan those are good
actually health and strength is your
highest level 212 right now yeah um oops
is Green Arrow's your alter-ego Mike -
don't know it demeans uh all three go
just go - my strength and health okay
cool I'll go with that actually it's not
school looking for whatever I could show
his doing any other skins for him I wish
I did I want this it's not even green
arrow anymore but he feels like you're
Evel Knievel or something yeah that
one's pretty cool I like this Joey Yi on
GameSpot uses this yeah all right um
show who do we want to L grid grid for
cyborg yeah and I don't know if there's
any other characters people want to see
some of this stuff for so this is grid
dang that's pretty cool yeah I didn't
unlock him unfortunately but I thought
you said you did I'm a TI you have to
lay through the story mode to actually
make it a double good but you know it's
probably gonna be in a platinum box or
something probably evil looks pretty
cool this is one I'm using no this one
I'm using right now I could use cyborg
in the future I like him a lot this is
cool - actually and I like red Superman
and Supergirl have really cool ones I
think it's just cool seeing them without
the classic like red blue yeah and then
this is one of those things I got an
epic that I can't use to level 20 just
happening I guess um
we got some new Robin stuff Edu's Robin
oh when I get for the flash once again
for those of you just tuned in this is
our game sports daily 11 o'clock stream
11 11 a.m. Pacific make sure to come
back tomorrow and Monday through Fridays
we'll be streaming games at 11 a.m.
every day and this in particular is kind
of an extension of reboot sort of it's a
show Mike and I do on GameSpot make sure
to check that out the recent one was
about injustice but basically Mondays
we're going to be streaming a game that
is kind of relevant to reboot maybe not
if there's nothing that we're really
interested in but yeah we just I'd do
injustice today if you guys are enjoying
this make sure to subscribe like and
feel free to ask us questions if you
want to see a certain character play or
if you want to see different outfits
whatever let us know Dan Robin is so
[ __ ] cool in this game Robin oh I got
new skins see what that looks like
that's pretty cool that one's like the
classic yeah
I like the red red it's pretty cool I
can play him a little bit um someone's
the captain ColdGear did I have much
I haven't played him at all as you can
tell I'm pretty early in the game I
think I've played like 10 hours but you
can at least yeah we can look through it
yeah I mean you can look through his
that's the basic that's pretty cool
oh I can equip that now I'll put that on
very cool I looked through his uh skins
though yeah I should rank it Stevie says
love GameSpot ever since inception thank
you so much uh zero Kelvin someone's the
doctor faith skin as well if I hang on
since s how long do you guys stream uh
11:00 a.m. - so it kind of depends
usually probably around an hour we'll
probably do about an hour today but it
can range from hour to two hours maybe
more days really into a game or
something here his Energy's known
screamo his skins are all pretty similar
actually yeah so for this one just to
freeze Wow
I want that uh right now I'll stick with
black ice though he's pretty cool like I
his ultimate is awesome but I did not
know who he was before I played this
game but I still kind of don't do you
remember Arnold Schwarzenegger as mr.
fresh now I remember mr. I don't mr.
freeze was yeah I know but you remember
yes before things it's done to cool off
I can show the AI battle simulator
actually not killed the dinosaurs
di stage Catwoman is she's tough I like
her but she's use I think green a Green
Lantern is not green Martian says what's
your favorite character Jake I think my
favorite character is I really like
Black Canary
I think blonde Black Canary might be my
favorite or Harley Quinn you like
playing Black Canary yeah alright show
dr. fate stuff he mine's red he's
usually not
step off here
any news on far cry mic like the
location release date they announced the
a that it's Montana or something right
yeah its Montana zone wild it's like
yeah Montana apparently like these I
think according the games like
right-wing radicalist take over like
radical people pick over and kind of it
just becomes this lawless Montana with
American interesting it is it modern-day
do we know yeah I think I don't know if
people were contemplating with being
Wild West yeah because the the teaser
they like oh we don't know much about it
other than a teaser yeah um someone
asked who's the hidden character in the
game I don't think we should spoil that
hidden character yeah there's one
character you unlock by eating the game
yeah I don't think we should spoil that
but I'm sure you can find it pretty
easily i actually i'm on the last
mission story so i I mean you get to a
point in the story where it's like
alright I know who is alright
does anybody know does anyone want me to
do anything specific I could show off
more than multiverse yeah I'm gonna
check my battlelog let us know what you
guys want to see
we'll probably stream for another 15
minutes or so yeah this is gonna have to
do more multiverse we can do single
fights you can see my a I team is not
doing too well so this is the AI you can
uh I'll show just to show people attack
someone oh this is where they fight by
themselves right
you like equip them and then yeah show
people so you see how my team does no no
no no this one looks like I could win
gube wants you to play online okay I
could try I'll do one um let's go my
attack a clean green arrow Harley and
[Music]
Batman maybe
do I'll do Batman alright see how see
how it goes so people know this is you
can make an AI team so even when you're
not playing you can come in the next
thing get a bunch of bronze loot boxes
and you can like you can do it I'm doing
now and I'm going to enable fast-forward
you just see how they do so there's my
green arrow against the level 12 Batman
from this dude I like if they don't have
to help Arthur's one yeah looks like I'm
oh [ __ ]
oh I blocked the ultimate yet yeah you
got him my god it's so fast alright so
now it's flat no Harley I got my Harley
coming up against so I see this a couple
people want to want to see you play
online okay I'll play online so after
this he'll do online maybe do a couple
rounds see okay so with my Harley
against that Superman clash I won the
clash got my health back he's gonna do
the same thing it looks like damn this
is pretty even come on Harley no no no
no no no
get some damn Superman one Rick so
though it's the librarian is shits my
Batman yes I wanted Deathstroke in this
game cyborg man was just saying that
maybe he'll be I didn't they show okay I
see how my Batman does he should win
this against let's level [ __ ] oh maybe
not you got it back it back yeah that
may not be enough Batman
lost eat alright everyone's like what
did I just see tell me that ends - is
this Dragon Ball Z I got a brother I got
a month new box what's uh
let me open that loop box then I'll go
into multiplayer let me decode this
bronze box see if I got it's not going
to give me anything worthwhile
supergirl arms and dr. fate torso all
right let's go online see how I fare
gonna get my ass kicked but it'll be fun
unless we find someone else doing the
same thing everyone is so confused about
that so we put it on a double speed okay
yeah so it was automated battle so you
can make you can make different teams
and then you they fight automatically
against other yeah the people have made
so you assign defenders so like the next
day when you load the game up people
will have it so I just picked someone to
attack and you watch that happen but
otherwise if they attack you you don't
have to be online that I'm it Mike
wasn't actually playing no so I did not
lose but in multiverse there is a fast
mode but I don't think you can ever do
it that time no it speeds up throughout
the yeah oh no not vs I want uh online
this will be interesting not to a ranked
match
let's do it
Oh someone said you called it a loop box
or maybe I probably called little loop
box
they are loop boxes much overwatch yeah
I mean what are they called in the
mother yeah I'm not gonna call it that
I've been calling the super moves in
this Ultimates yeah speaking of blue box
oh yeah Joey's doing the overwatch loop
boxing tomorrow oh he's at our stream
for Mom level 25 guy 26 and 23 online
damn alright
who's he playing as Batman maybe I'll go
Green Arrow just because it's your best
phone right might as well guess so see
how this works out
pick Deadshot and do that thing that
they was document go gorilla City I love
those little interactions
man look at go on ace he needs to pick
up
there's just loading yeah pick up man
they'll be funny if this guy was
watching the stream right I was
approaching gorilla City
oh yeah Google stream over over watches
8 isn't it the overwatch stream time is
8 right oh I don't know if I am yeah
this goes I think that's when it's
supposed to drop but we're kind of
hesitant to do it just because uh just
in case it doesn't drop like alright
I'll see how this goes someone to know
what's worse Superman quest for peace or
Batman and Robin I mean I don't know I
haven't seen Superman quest release or
reddit or whatever so I'll have to go
through that man Robin what do you think
is worse Superman question piece are
Batman and Robin you want to see us play
each other - yeah is that connected yeah
it is we can plug that one in I'll get
my I'll get my butt kicked
LeAnn we can close out on one game like
that so I won't talk he's he's
concentrating stop talking me okay I'm
not allowed to talk to him what's good
chat damn this guy's
we'll call it mother loot box yeah Danna
it's got mighty me I threw his badly as
I thought I would you're doing pretty
bad though I'm just kidding
he's got a super to
like that yeah damn
I might not miss him or I might hit me
I'm a pocket he's could use his right
now if you wanted to doesn't need to of
course it would finish this ooh
get in there oh yeah yeah uh damn not
terrible [ __ ] Batman you know try one
more yeah
got some guild points for guild game
spot which is just you yep you can join
if you want the tag tag is spot doesn't
ID Erte I made one right that Joey and
uh I think better into their same try
ranged attacks oh I was trust me yeah
stop talking
not on top oh is it best of three for
these no we just rematch nice group says
I don't know how good Mike is it
overwatch not very good not very good
you don't want him on you team better
than Nick margarita it's true
it's a stress Oh
oh [ __ ] I wasn't blocking that smack
life wants Eminem in one of these games
and then when he wins does rap God wins
Ted good there you go I got the arrows
sticking up there he's gonna keep trying
to
[Music]
so you can sneak in a super oh [ __ ] now
he's gonna be late get up and be smart
yeah just back myself into a corner I
was dumb
yeah damn done with this dude
did you want to blame me I don't think
we have it almost every day if you ever
do go okay all right we'll do it one on
one match I'm gonna get my I'm gonna get
my ass kicked and someone's gonna talk
her interact with the chat there you go
ah you got to leave that plugged in
whoops otherwise I can't connect all
right there we go um should be all right
cool you see the whole history of
GameSpot people here to even hit there
hey guys Jake Oh Danny still I should
delete Danny isn't uh he actually take
that out now cuz that's annoying me
hopefully it doesn't stop but hopefully
it does pull out while you're will do
vs. oh wait hold on I got it I got a new
uh
box someone fought me I lost all right
here we go we gonna play oh jeez I don't
even know maybe Wonder Woman wait let's
uh do we have Oh should we see what they
want us to play yeah who should I be who
shat yeah let us know we should play
this is Mike right here I'm Jake just
say Jake play this Mike play that kind
of want play character we don't just
don't say dark side cuz we don't have
dark side
I have Mike place him when he's never
played before then have me play like
black canary or Wonder Woman yeah
probably get dark side just to happen
Jake big flash flash first when I see
I'm gonna play oh they both said flash
so
hi V [ __ ] oh that's cheetah [ __ ] my bed
rather close Maddie
alright um picking in red Sun prints
dark side that was the one thing I said
knock Sheamus all right we got it
we'll see how this turns out I might
have to check my mouthing on Xbox too so
Oh actually everything's reversed so you
have to use the d-pad to attack and okay
and then the the Facebook all right
let's uh it's a really good
we try to grab you too yeah whoo damn he
almost got it I tried to jump that's
always my reaction when I try to jump
and it works for some of him but her
doesn't work coz I'm late and I still
get hit by it but I need to do is -
backwards yeah let me check my move
looks really quick nonsense
oh I should check mine - over here
nonsenses make sure the last match is
Superman force patent we should finish
with that yeah we could she's boring
tisn't grabs attacks are really good
what oh [ __ ] I'm hitting the wrong
buttons we made the wrong bugs damn
it's getting close jakey I really like
the flash cuz how dumb is baddest yeah
for [ __ ] dogs and uh eating its food
just get smacked in the fatal idea what
species just attack it happens them all
the time - crab oh oh damn is close good
match
that was it one more bad answer I did
way better than I thought it wait who
are you gonna be Superman or Batman um
boss says hey guys I'm a vegan Thanks
yeah should we do super members Batman
sure um back side of this quick I don't
care I mean I think I'm probably better
with Batman okay all the soups I played
him a little bit yesterday where's
Superman um what would be inappropriate
I guess read stunt no let's do
Metropolis let's do this bar fight I
like you could throw the people turn get
the bar happy other fighter it doesn't
align with some of the characters like I
wonder woman I would never do that
yeah no Wonder Woman kind of wonder what
is yeah but just like still sing Wonder
Woman like the last of it
oh yeah he'll
laser power laser try eyes
you may fight check move let's quick
after those hit me what is my all right
oh wait were you ready all right
miss it's funny only miss cuz it's just
a dude who's gonna the ground
let's forgot his lake no that's not it
that's not it either that was okay I
guess remember his yeah I tried walking
that didn't work this one's really good
I like his - I feel like I've seen it by
far the most out of all of them though
you know yeah I wish everybody had like
a couple I know me too damn this is cool
it's it's satisfying especially if
you're beating up a character you hate
because it's just [ __ ] punch it as
hard as possible and then grab in her
face and then thrown them
douche bag I love that oh man there we
go
those are good though I didn't get my
asking me as much as I thought I want to
plays more in the office but call did
he's not on these out too sweet I think
that's about it thank you guys for
stopping by
make sure to check out reboot too it was
all about injustice yeah if you wanna
know more about injustice you're curious
to see what the show we are working on
more like sure to check that out my
perspective is a newcomer to fighting
game not a newcomer I've dabbled like an
hour - and pretty much every fighting
game I want yeah an but this is the one
that's really pulled me in and for a few
good reasons pretty accessible in a
great way I think that's kind of a
negative term a lot but this game uses
it to its advantage and uh I know you're
pretty much joined this game too but
yeah I'm having fun as well and then
also like I said I think I said a couple
times but we stream every day now Monday
through Friday 11:00 a.m. Pacific for
about our - so make sure to stop by and
check that out I think that's about it
though thank you guys for watching yeah
I'll see you guys around should then
ready with the outro later
[Music]